je te vois dans 10 ans
[Musique]
je crois que je serais mort avant
honnêtement
nous allons donc parler des adolescents
car pour eux on le sait assez
précisément 9 disparitions sur 10 ce
sont des fûts alors c'est un phénomène
majeur de notre société avec toujours au
départ un bouleversement familial
jusqu'au moment où ces jeunes plein de
désespoir ne peuvent plus ou ne veulent
plus retourner chez eux des espoirs
regardez c'est bien le mot qui convient
dans ce reportage de Jeanne Lagier et de
Jacques Douai
[Musique]
parce que mon père
voit de temps en temps
et quand il rentre
il se dispute
avec ma mère c'est ça
tu as réussi à monter dans les autres
sur Paris sans payer ton ticket
[Musique]
comme ça c'est très bien au fond de toi
qu'on va trop trouver non si c'est pas
le premier jour ce sera le deuxième le
troisième comment veux-tu qu'on laisse
le un gamin comme ça tout seul sans
argent sans famille sans manger dehors
c'est pas possible c'est bien qu'il y a
des gens qui font des contrôles
[Musique]
tu as pas pensé à tout ça
et finalement tu es content ou pas
d'avoir été interpellé
est-ce que tu es certaine façon
repartir avec tes parents
ah c'est toi qui dit qu'il t'aime pas
moi je suis pas du tout sûr
il y a sûrement des problèmes chez vous
alors
[Musique]
je les aime pas
du pardon
comme Mustapha chaque année en France
plus de 100 000 enfants sont en fugue il
partent parce qu'il ne supporte plus le
silence de leurs parents le manque
d'amour et de compréhension ainsi
Ivan 17 ans est resté plusieurs mois
dehors entièrement livré à lui-même
lorsque tu avais 16 ans ça n'allait pas
à la maison qu'est-ce qui se passait
déjà je m'entendais pas à mon père parce
qu'il me frappait il était assez violent
parce que j'ai l'école ça me plaisait
pas
pour lui j'étais agressif
et moi j'ai à la fin j'ai la mémoire
et ma mère doit laisser chaque fois de
se mettre au milieu et j'arrive pas
à rien faire il aurait souhaité que tu
sois comment ton père
qui sort de l'école avec je sais pas
combien de diplôme un petit bien comme
il faut un peu de son genre à lui et toi
et son genre à lui c'est quoi
qui a fait les études le travail qui
regarde que le travail et style un peu
vieux jeu
tu restais plusieurs mois livré à
toi-même à la campagne comment vivais-tu
la journée j'essayais de trouver du
travail de de contacter des personnes
des paysans pas mal de gens pour voir
travailler gagner un peu de sous même si
on peut gagner des sous mais nourri logé
et puis bon arrivé à la tombée de la
nuit quand je voyais que j'ai trouvé pas
de travail rien pas d'embauche j'allais
campagne j'allais voir c'est un des
maisons isolées
je voulais maison j'allais dormir dedans
mais sans aucun mal juste dormir manger
si j'ai trouvé des vêtements propres
m'habiller
c'était
c'était pour une hygiène besoin de
dormir
j'avais toujours l'impression de me
faire attraper
toujours peur la peur à moi seul et tout
et puis j'étais toujours dans l'angoisse
je dormais pas beaucoup et la nuit je
vais dormir dans la maison
parce qu'après je sortais le matin juste
au lever du jour je sortais des maisons
bon je repartais la journée j'irai faire
la route
après des fois ils sont arrivés d'avoir
sommeil j'ai dormi dans un champ une
journée après je reparte à la comédie
je voulais montrer à mon père que
j'étais capable de me démerder seul que
j'ai pas besoin de lui
c'est comme une mamie dehors moi je me
suis pensé que c'était une expérience et
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas demandé au
cours de la femme
et je me suis démerdé seul
tu ne pouvais parler à personne non
j'ai déjà dit pas c'était pas intéressé
ça t'a rendu un peu sauvage
j'ai beaucoup changé
et quelles étaient les sentiments de ton
père à ton égard durant tout ce temps
de parler de moi
même quand j'étais dans la galère si je
me suis rapproché à côté de la maison
pour aller chercher
pourtant tu étais mineur il avait la
responsabilité de toi mais lui il s'en
fout
la galère qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est
un manque d'affection déjà ça part déjà
de la
c'est être seul pas avoir des gens
auprès de soi bien comme il faut qu'il
nous aide
il y a de bons moments dans une galère
jamais jamais eu de bons moments
où trouves-tu l'argent pour vivre
des fois ça m'arrive quand
j'ai galéré j'ai pas eu souvent mais
j'avais des fois dans les églises
je vais prendre les sous dans les
petits paniers
là
tu avais repéré quelques couvents
dans un courant j'ai pris des sous
tu as été pris par les flics tu as vu le
juge tu as fait de la prison quel
souvenir tu gardes tout ça
que des mauvais souvenirs
c'est des trucs que je vais essayer
d'oublier et de continuer notre vie mais
comme il faut la prison c'est quoi
c'est
[Musique]
bon j'étais à moi-même il y avait
quelque chose qui allait pas
j'étais un peu dépressif
nerveux
et j'avais toujours la crainte aussi de
savoir ce que j'allais faire ce que
j'allais devenir
ça non plus que c'est le plus qui me
travaillais c'était pour l'avenir pour
savoir parce que pas mal de gens qui
mettaient délinquants que c'était pas
vrai et que je n'étais pas c'était pour
ça
et aujourd'hui
quels sont tes sentiments vis-à-vis de
ton père
j'ai deux sentiments vers lui
ce qui s'est passé tout
ça c'est un truc j'ai oublié jamais ça
c'est un truc qui reste mais
je l'aime bien je sais pas pourquoi avec
tout le monde qui l'a fait je l'aime
bien
est-ce que tu penses que tu vas t'en
sortir maintenant
et je pense que je m'en sortirai j'ai la
volonté pour m'en sortir
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
je vais faire une autre chien je ne
sécurité mais en même temps tu vas
tu vas traquer les jeunes les autres
ça te gêne pas non non
c'est pas une vengeance mais ça n'est
une en même temps
comme Yvan alexis a quitté très tôt le
domicile de ses parents mais pour gagner
de l'argent il a choisi lui la
prostitution
tu as fait ta première fugue à 14 ans tu
t'es prostituée tout de suite
j'avais
déjà goûté à ça une
occasion comme ça en faisant draguer à
Montparnasse
par un vieux con comme tout les clients
qui sont dans ce milieu là
et
j'ai commencé d'abord par les vols les
vols la cam
je dis les un peu ensuite je me suis
prostitué en effet
comment les pédophiles les hommes plus
âgés vous repèrent vous les jeunes en
fugue
faut voir c'est marqué sur notre front
enfin ils ont plutôt tendance à draguer
n'importe qui un petit jeune qui leur
plaît qui a l'air assez sexy
il aborde je te paye un verre
si tu as le malheur de dire oui bon tu
es parti tu es en Grenade
ce prostituer avec des hommages j'ai
pour un jeune comme toi qu'est-ce que ça
signifie
c'est dégueulasse
mais c'est une façon de gagner de
l'argent assez facilement
surtout moi qui aurait plutôt tendance à
être violent avec eux ce serait plutôt
l'arnaque
je j'annonce le prix mais en fait
j'arrive souvent sous une porte cochère
en vidant le porte-monnaie
mais c'est assez dur surtout quand on a
un client qui a un vocabulaire plutôt
bizarre qui arrive vers vous
le type pourrait être facilement votre
grand-père et qui vous dit tu prends
combien est-ce que tu te fais [__]
on va où chez toi tu fais ça dans les
parkings
c'est pas toujours évident encaisser à
14 ans Alexis ça fait sa première fugue
comment vous avez réagi alors
cette fois là j'ai été très angoissé si
actuellement j'arrive à me contrôler et
réagir j'ai appris
les premières fugues ont été pour moi
quelque chose d'abominable j'étais à y
penser à Sens et ça me demandait où il
était dans ce qui lui arrivait à
demander s'il était vivant même Xavier
peur j'avais très peur
surtout quand j'ai découvert la première
fugue qu'il est
ce qu'il avait fait du moins j'arrivais
pas à y croire réellement mais c'est
chez un homosexuel que je les retrouvais
à partir du moment où il m'a appelé au
secours tu es homosexuel pas du tout
alors tu le vis comment malheureusement
pas du tout parce que
en faisant en faisant ce boulot là parce
que en fait on peut appeler ça un boulot
comme on peut appeler ça ce qu'on veut
c'est plutôt dur de ne pas l'être
quand je me retrouve avec un client j'ai
vraiment l'impression c'est quelque
chose de dégoûtant c'est peut-être une
pensée un peu tabou mais j'ai vraiment
l'impression de coucher avec mon père
parce que
une personne âgée comme ça qui profite
du corps d'un gamin c'est vraiment
dégueulasse tout ça pour trois
malheureux billets de 100 francs si on
te
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour un père
fils qui se prostitue
pour un père
je pense qu'elle doit dépendre pour moi
ce qui m'a ça m'a fait ça a été une
grande souffrance
non pas de la honte pour moi c'est
pas important ça
c'est que Alexis n'est pas un homosexuel
il a des petites amies il aime les
filles
je ne crois pas qu'il aime
faire quoi que ce soit avec des hommes
donc ça a été quelque chose qui pour lui
était une atteinte très profonde je sais
que c'est quelque chose qui pour lui est
humiliant et vous vous le vivez comment
je le vis je supporte pour moi c'est
c'est pas moi qui qui suis la victime de
cette chose là
Alexis tu as 17 ans est-ce que tu vis
beaucoup dans le passé
trop
beaucoup trop
je vois je vois parce que j'ai vécu le
problème de famille
ce que m'a fait ma mère
l'abondon de ma mère que je vis très mal
et
le fait de vivre par le passé a beaucoup
beaucoup abîmé ma vie en fait
tu as le sentiment d'avoir été abandonné
par ta mère complètement parce que même
si elle me contacte encore maintenant de
temps en temps j'ai plus l'impression
que c'est ma mère
elle voulait pas elle voulait pas d'un
deuxième gosse je l'ai pas digéré je
suis gêné par ça dans sa petite enfance
il s'est très tôt sentir jeté par sa
mère il n'a pratiquement jamais été
élevé par sa mère et il y a un besoin de
ce côté là en même temps qu'un besoin
d'un soutien de ma part qui ne reçoit
sans doute pas assez pour des raisons
assez complexes vous avez divorcé vous
êtes marié quels sont les rapports de
votre fils avec sa belle-mère
actuellement très mauvais extrêmement
tendu
il n'est plus accepté du tout pour ma
femme c'est le c'est un gros problème
actuellement il a une mauvaise attitude
elle s'occupe mal de mon père mal de ma
sœur moi bon bah de toute façon elle
veut plus du tout s'occuper de moi c'est
c'est fini je crois que actuellement on
a rompu les liens définitivement le juge
vous a retiré la garde de votre fils ça
signifie que vous étiez un mauvais père
objectivement j'ai pas été à mon père
pour Alexis mais si le juge me retiré
cette garde ce n'est pas parce que je
suis à malépère c'est parce que je lui
ai demandé pourquoi mon ménage à moi
allait être détruit et Alexis vous en
veut il m'en veut il a le sentiment
d'avoir été abandonné c'est vrai
j'ai besoin de m'éloigner de tous mes
problèmes j'ai besoin de vivre autre
chose de rencontrer des gens
et puis chaque fois que je suis un fût
je cherche quelque chose de bien précis
c'est l'amour l'amour qu'on m'a pas
donné
mais justement la prostitution c'est une
menace que tu fais peser sur ton père
c'est une façon de toucher en plein cœur
c'est je l'ai blessé là où il fallait en
commençant ça et je continue là-dessus
parce que ça l'aide vachement à prendre
conscience de ce qui m'a fait
tu le puni
en quelque sorte
la prostitution est-ce que ça t'a changé
profondément
ça m'a endurci ça m'a rendu sévère
parce que je vois plus les choses la
même façon je suis plus comme les jeunes
de mon âge qui faisons leur petit cocon
papa maman qu'il est surveille je rentre
ce soir 7h souper à regarder la télé un
peu on va se coucher on fait ses devoirs
je vais plus du tout comme ça n'est pas
honte pour toi
ça a été au début ça m'a ça m'a assez
choqué oui mais plus maintenant
c'est c'est la routine c'est quelque
chose de banal
durant tes fûts de te sentir seul je
suis toujours seul
pas seulement dans mes fugues dans ma
vie je suis seul
je crois que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut supporter
c'est comme ça c'est j'en souffre
beaucoup parce que moi je voudrais
je voudrais pouvoir donner de l'amour à
quelqu'un parce que je pense en être
capable aussi puis je voudrais surtout
pouvoir en recevoir
je voudrais finir ma vie avec une femme
que j'aime avoir des gosses et puis qui
soit vraiment plus heureux que j'ai pu
être
[Musique]
c'est ici à Châtelet-les-Halles la plus
grande station de métro du monde au
transit chaque jour 250 000 voyageurs
que font escale de nombreux fugueurs et
jeunes en galère
ils viennent de tous les horizons
attirés par la réputation du forum et du
quartier des Halles à 20 mètres sous
terre la gare avec ses dédales et ses
tunnels leur offre un abri et un toit
pour dormir
riant rompu toutes les amarres
familiales scolaires et sociales ils
cherchent à se regrouper pour trouver
chaleur et sécurité ce ne sont pas des
bandes organisées structurées mais de
petits groupes éphémères qui se font et
se défont selon les aléas de leur vie
agité la gare et les halles deviennent
leur territoire une sorte de cour des
miracles où il tente de survivre
Stéphane depuis combien de temps tu vis
à la rue ça fait deux ans non 4 ans
maintenant 3 ans
de dire que je compte même plus les
années
c'est difficile de vivre à la rue
c'est où tu marches ou tu crèves
et tu marches
dans un compte tu vois dans une rue au
déserte où tu cherches pendant malade
pour savoir si tu vas bouffer si tu vas
pouvoir assurer ta petite bière
ou dors-tu
en ce moment dehors
dormir en dessous je vais peut-être
dormir là je sais pas trop
la galère m'aide dans la rue être mal
enfin être mal faire ce qu'on veut enfin
pas faire ce qu'on veut mais
vivre avec des copains et se démerder
comme on peut
bébé enfant de la danse squatte dans le
quartier depuis le jour de ses 18 ans
ses parents nourriciers ne touchant plus
de subventions l'ont alors jeté à la rue
[Musique]
Stéphane cette vie de galère que tu
mènes c'est un choix
dans un sens ça va être un choix parce
que quand jamais mes parents je pouvais
partir de moi comme ça galère mais
disons que j'avais tout le temps du fric
puis qu'ils sont les CD aussi puis un
jour
tu les as perdu comment je parlais dans
un accident de train enfin symptômes 85
de temps qu'il soit son percutés
ensemble en dessous notre tunnel ça
s'est passé du côté de l'Italie enfin je
sais plus trop où et
là
[Musique]
je me sentais séquestrée surtout que
j'avais pas le droit de sortir bon
d'aller au cinéma toute seule ou aller
avec une copine ou aller en ville ou
n'importe quoi et j'arrivais pas à me
plaire chez mes parents c'est pour ça
que je suis parti
[Musique]
pendant combien de temps as-tu vécu à la
rue un an et demi qu'est-ce qui était le
plus dur
pour dormir le soir déjà parce que
l'hiver c'était assez dur et quand ça je
l'ai vraiment fort c'était dur
et autrement
les métros dans le RER le RER car il va
Mitry il arrivait à 1h 1h30 et il
repartait le matin à 5h ce qui faisait
que on avait seulement que 4 heures pour
dormir et la journée on était vraiment
assommé quoi
ils ont rien font deux s'il vous plaît
merci
c'est gentil de répondre déjà
vous êtes au chômage
[Musique]
on se démerde comme on peut c'est
surtout ça parce que moi je préfère
faire la manche que de voler déjà bon on
a tous plus ou moins volé dans notre vie
on n'est pas descendre quoi
de gens c'est un peu dur faut chauffer
quoi se chauffer mais
pour ça il y en a qui qui chute qui se
drogue quoi mais moi c'est enfin moi
c'est pas mon cas mais moi je prends des
médicaments quoi comme genre élixir
Elixia c'est un petit flacon ou qu'on
boit tout le flacon et enfin ça dépend
la dose et bon on est chaud pour faire
la manche il y en a d'autres ça veut
dire quoi chaud ça veut dire qu'on est
bien dans sa peau quoi parce que moi je
me lève le matin je serais bien tu je
pourrais pas attaquer les gens comme ça
quoi pour leur demander un front ou deux
alors je suis obligé de boire quelque
chose comme si j'étais bourré mais pas
bourré quoi bien
comme Bébert tous en besoin de drogue
pour se donner du courage et calmer
l'angoisse toujours présente
toute la journée il se bourre de
haschich ou de barbiturique mélangé à de
la bière ce qui les plonge dans un état
second de délire et d'excitation grâce
aux réseaux de dealer solidement
implanté dans le quartier ils n'ont
aucune difficulté à se procurer leur
dose quotidienne
[Musique]
au lieu de prendre la drogue vous
preniez des cachets oui parce que
c'était le moins cher
et pour ceux qui étaient en main qui
pouvaient prendre des cachets parce que
ça ça calme quoi et pour vous pour moi
moi j'ai jamais pris de l'héroïne et la
cocaïne donc moi j'en prenais je crois
que pour faire au début c'était pour
faire comme les autres puis après j'en
ai pris goût quoi pour oublier tu
galères seul ou un groupe on galère
c'est un mec qui galère seul il est mal
quoi enfin je sais pas moi j'ai toujours
galéré été un groupe mais on est bien on
sent pas tout seul quoi
tout seul on sait pas quoi faire on est
déprimé et on sent seul on a envie de
pleurer ou on en met des fois il y en a
qui a envie de se suicider carrément
alors faut mieux être en groupe et on en
parle jamais notre solitude ou quoi que
ce soit si quelqu'un parle de nos soucis
tout le monde
tout le monde est déprimé quoi il y en a
un qui en parle et puis l'autre puis
l'autre et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on faisait durant toute une
journée on restait à la fontaine à
rester
comme ça sur le sur les trucs de les
marbre les bandes la fontaine et au
restait là-bas parce que quand on était
à 5 après il y en avait d'autres qui
arrivaient tout ça on les attendait ce
qui fait que la journée passée comme ça
je suis la police à brigade des mineurs
là je voudrais savoir si vous avez une
pièce d'identité là j'ai une
4%. qu'est-ce que vous faites ici là
vous avez l'autorisation
à tes parents
[Applaudissements]
ça allait de 6 à 8 fois par jour si
c'était pas plus parce qu'on allait au
niveau - 4 alors il y avait au moins 12
pieds qui se ramènent d'un coup alors
nous disait de dégagé hop on allait à la
fontaine fontaine on avait d'autres à la
Beaubourg et ainsi de suite mais nous
connaissez par cœur et il savait qu'on
prenait des cachets et tout ça ce qui
fait qu'ils en avaient marre de nous
voir ils partaient on nous faisait
partir ou alors carrément si on partait
pas il nous foutait 4 heures dans une
cellule
[Musique]
le quartier des Halles qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour toi
de merde
pourquoi par exemple
il y a les flics
quand on vit comme tu vis
commence
toute façon tu as pas le choix en fait
[Musique]
peut-être une grosse glace mais moi
j'aime pas le faire filmer tu vois sinon
les mecs qui me filent des tunes parce
que moi je suis pas de [__] tu vois
on sait que tu es plus fort on sait ça
et ça nous ferait chier qu'il se passe
tabasser de chez toi
non mais là
tu vois dans 10 ans
[Musique]
je crois que je serai mort avant
honnêtement ce sera mort de quoi
[Musique]